well police say the gunman in a northern
California shooting rampage hit his
wife's body under the floorboards of his
house Kevin Neal killed for other people
Tuesday before police killed him
surveillance video shows how he targeted
a local school Jamie yuccas is at Rancho
Tehama elementary where we're learning
just how close it came to a massacre
Jamie good morning good morning school
superintendent Rick Fitzpatrick says
he's been getting calls from schools
throughout the country including
officials from Newtown who have been
praising the quick action here however
Fitzpatrick is thinking a custodian who
he says distracted the shooter getting
more children into classrooms and out of
harm's way
nobody panicked everybody did what they
were supposed to do and we're all alive
to tell about it
school district superintendent Rick
Fitzpatrick took us through the
horrifying details of the gunman
shooting spree at Rancho Tehama
elementary kevin neil reached the school
as the teachers were completing the
lockdown
he ran the gate with his truck at the
north end of campus he then exited the
vehicle with a semi-automatic rifle in
hand our head custodian
who was shepherding kids in a class
poked his head around the corner to see
what it was made eye contact with the
shooter the shooter engaged him and
almost immediately had problems with his
rifle it looks like it jammed
those few seconds that the custodian was
able to distract him allowed us to get
those kids into the room Fitzpatrick
says the shooter then ran into the
center of the school grounds at that
time he opened fire on the windows and
the doors and the walls of the
classrooms in the quad on all three
sides he was looking to kill people
his face was filled with violence and
and quite frankly the word that easily
comes to mind is evil there was no doubt
in my mind that he intended to take life
and as many as you could without being
able to gain entry the shooter became
frustrated and eventually left at a
vigil last night we spoke with Jennifer
Bauman a first and second grade teacher
at the school
who helped lock it down you trained for
it you never really expect
they just jumped in action and did what
was natural to us evil didn't win
yesterday we won all our kids went home
and that's a big deal
police believe the shooter built the
assault rifles he used in this shooting
that's because last February there was a
restraining order in place after an
assault with a deadly weapon that would
have prevented him from purchasing or
owning firearms at that time he did turn
in weapons we're told the two handguns
found by officials did belong to someone
else Charlie thanks Jamie